oh boy so monolingual no Italian and no
English monolingual no Italian no
English what do you choose I I know it's
on the
spot so I got a sense of overwhelm and
you know was like the smelly uncle that
you like talking to but then it's a
little bit too much and you just want to
walk away and find your peace is your
body ready for some of these questions
my body my body my mind and my soul
they're all
ready uh we're going to expose some of
your secrets and by expose I mean we're
just going to talk uh We've collected
some questions here from people within
your very Community within the circle
community at the Smart language learning
academy and also some questions I myself
may have sprinkled in but I won't say
which ones so without further Ado is
your body ready for some of these
questions my body my body my mind and my
soul they're all ready question was
what's your favorite language my answer
is languages are like members of of a
family they come like the family is
getting bigger and bigger and I it's
like asking you whether you like more
like your father or your mother right I
would say I love them all but there are
languages that I like that I like more
or I like learning more than others I
take I take care try to take care of all
of them but I would say
that Russian
Greek German these are my favorite
languages Russian Greek and German
Russian Greek and German okay and which
language which since you said it's like
your family which which language for you
is that that weird uncle that kind of
smells bad comes over randomly
unexpectedly he gets too close to you uh
you still love him dearly because he's
very fun but sometimes you're just like
it's too much Uncle I'm sorry get away
from me which language did you say I
think that that that was that was the
impression I had the feeling I had when
I was learning Japanese back in the day
because it was overwhelming I find it
difficult I was not learning it the
right way a was a disaster for me
because it was not like as good as the
other uh as the other languages uh you
know that I love Asim that's for those
who don't know what Asim is it's just a
resource for beginners I love it I I've
been using it for pretty much every
language but for Asian languages it's
not that great so I got a sense of
overwhelm and you know was like the
smelly uncle that you like talking to
but then it's a little bit too much and
you just want to walk away and find your
peace Sugo Sugo sug
what are some things you've been able to
do in foreign languages that you likely
wouldn't have been able to do without
those
languages uh pretty much everything like
for example let's start with uh having a
job like this one that I I run a company
that revolves around language learning I
would not have been able to pull this uh
pull this off without speaking a bunch
of languages uh creating a YouTube
channel talking about language learning
get getting to know a lot of people a
lot of friends and get to know a lot of
girlfriends and partners uh who speak
different languages so uh these are the
things like basic things that come to
mind when it comes to speaking a bunch
of languages um because languages can
change your life not not just externally
right not the circumstances and the
amount of people and the amount of
girlfriends or whatever Partners or
whatever you want to call it um but I
think that um I'm able to look like from
holistically right I'm able to look at
the world in a different way this is
what I'm able to do uh I think that's
the that's the best ability I've gotten
is not just speaking a bunch of
languages it's not just about you
know improving my life when it comes to
traveling living in countries getting to
know people it's the capacity of looking
at the world through the language GL
lens as I call it and so I think I live
a better life as a consequence of that
that's that's that's what I would say
it's not just specific things because
there's a bunch of things that I've been
able to do um you know and I'm able to
do when it comes
to you know my my life in general uh but
it's it's just a different getting a
different perspective uh you know
hovering over the world and looking at
it you know I I really like this um the
movie Dead boy Society right where the
professor Robin Williams just stands on
the desk and says just stand up and just
the mere fact that you're um standing up
on a desk or on a table makes you look
at the room from a different perspective
and I think a language learning does
that uh when it comes to your life it's
just it's just changes you can see
things that other people can't see and
and I'm privileged I'm honored and
privileged that um that I'm able to do
that and uh that's the reason why I
always say guys girls people learn
languages because it's going to change
your life it's not just one even if you
learn just one foreign language well
it's going to change the perspective
someone said someone very wise said a
couple of hundred years ago I can't
remember the quote the exact quote but
he said you know if you learn another
language then you start learning
understanding yours your not only your
language but your own world much better
because you have a different
perspective we didn't know you're going
to make us cry luuka
okay hard-hitting question here then if
you couldn't choose Italian or English
but you could only speak one language
from here on out which language would it
be in why so no Italian no English and
only one language you go back to
monolingual life I know man oh man
that's a difficult that's that's really
really difficult because I'm already
thinking of all the consequences if I go
one route or go the other route I would
h I don't know I would I I would
probably choose English because of sir I
have to cut you off there we can't
choose
English oh you can't choose English you
can't choose English or
Italian so wait another like so I have
to pick up one language that I would
speak if I if my Italian and and and
English uh died in my head right correct
but that's the only language you could
use from here on
out oh boy so
no Italian and no English monolingual no
Italian no English what do you choose I
know it's on
spot probably Spanish probably Spanish
because it's one of the most spoken
languages in the world I have a lot of
friends from South America and Spain and
I'm happy when to speak Spanish what are
some of your favorite places to visit in
Italy I would say let me think about it
Florence uh apart from my native real
obviously um I would say Florence Tuscan
in general which is a region not far
from Rome let's say Tas Florence San
jinana which is a little little town in
the let's say in the outskirts of Sienna
Sienna itself which is another wonderful
wonderful place I love palmo too which
is in cisy deep uh deep down there in
the
South and um well there's many other
places but these are the two places
especially like the region tascan and
Palo these are the the two uh places or
regions or cities that I love going to
because of the people the food and how I
feel normally when it comes to visiting
a place that's what really makes a
difference is how I feel okay it's it's
your last day of life for some reason
you know whatever you believe in has
whispered to you that this is your last
day of your life uh where would you like
or what would you like your last view to
be if you could pick any any place in
the
world
oh boy this is a tough one um I would
say a beach in ten so Tena is you know
the Canary Islands or Canary Islands I'm
not sure how to Canary sir okay Canary
Canary okay stress on SEC on the second
syllable and I went there and I went
there in uh
2022 in April and I I I find that a
place where um you know going back to to
question number one about the places I
love I didn't mention TI fit but this is
another one uh you know that I love uh
just the mere idea of spending time
there because I did spend time there I
loved it I loved how I felt and if it
were the last day of my life or
Humanity's life for that matter
existence for that matter because a big
meteorite is about to hit Earth Earth
that's where I would like to be I would
like to be uh in that apartment where I
stay back in the day where I could see
like the r Mountain it's called the Red
Mountain literally and there's a beach
just in front of me and I would like to
stay there just like sit down relax and
think this is the last day of my life
I'm spending it in Paradise uh what LCA
what is the most stereotypically Italian
thing about
you I would say a couple of things that
I eat pasta every day and that I use my
my hands a lot uh in the Italian way
because mind you hand gestures everybody
uses hands but there's different ways of
using your hands for example cool speed
gestures are the gestures that accompany
speech when you see someone on tat talk
for example no matter where they're from
they use this gesture this gesture this
gesture these are Universal gestures but
then you have hand gestures are just you
know typical uh or unique to the Italian
culture and when I speak Italian I use
these hand gestures all all the time
sometimes we don't even realize how
timeing we look when we talk on the
phone where we talk with other people so
that is the one thing that sticks out
like a sore thumb when I talk to my
friends and um the other thing is I I
love eating pasta I know this is
stereotypical um and back in the day
when I was like 15 or 14 and I never
explore the world and the rest of the
world had never been abroad I thought it
Everybody Eats pasta twice a day and the
moment when when for example I met my
ex-girlfriend's parents ex-girlfriend
Chi was from ver Paris let's put it
simply um I was astounded and perplexed
by the fact that they did like pasta but
not that much they ate it maybe once uh
once a month and I was asking myself how
do these people survive without pasta
you know so pasta hand
gestures past and gestures let's say
that there's like the most typical and
then there's a few other I get
typical things when it comes to um to me
being Italian maybe that um what happens
often is that you know in Italy we go to
the coffee shop like around the corner
and we talk to the to the guy or like
the girl who works there or the people
work there in Italy I don't know about
Belgrade I don't know about Serbia but
you go to a place and it's not just like
um you
know just a professional relationship
hello I would like some coffee thank you
here it is that's it as it is in Poland
so another thing that maybe I think one
of of the features that I have is that
when I go to places when I go places so
to speak when I go and grab a coffee I
like talking to people and sometimes
especially abroad and people go like
what does this guy want like why why is
he being so friendly you can see for
example that as much as I love Poland
the conversation is kind of dry when it
comes to these like Starbucks places and
there's a lot of them caffino is an
example there's a lot of cafino all
around woro you go there hello proo and
you you go like Cav so like I like I
like coffee blah blah blah that's it you
know so I love talking to people I don't
know about Serbia but I think serbians
have a lot in common or a lot alike like
like us Italians that's my impression
yes I might be wrong they actually
dubbed me the American when I go uh when
I go to the local bakery um because what
happens is when I order something I'm
usually wearing shorts and pretty much
nobody's wearing shorts and you know
five degree weather out here so as soon
as I walk in they don't even know me
they don't know my name or anything they
hey
amerid or in Serbian it would be
americat so yes and so now every time I
walk in they're like hey if I'm not
wearing shorts they will call me out on
it they'll be like where are your shorts
and you know I my arm could be falling
off I could come in with like a cast and
they would say where are your shorts
so excellent well luuka you have
received a request from some of our very
own smart language learning academy
members to share some of your accents
that you like to um employ during random
conversations okay well uh let's start
with this I'd like to share now it's a
little bit different different because
normally when it's spontaneous that's a
different matter but now I'm speaking
with uh what is to be considered like a
South like let's say American Engish
from the south like in Texas or
something something like that I'm not
sure don't you be David states there boy
because what's going to happen is
someone in the comment is gonna be from
that state and they're going to say it
ain't like that boy well that's true
they got to figure it out themselves I
believe that's that's important
um then when it comes to I can switch to
I'm not supposed to call what this
accent is actually like that's the
reason why I'm not saying anything but I
would like to point out that I'm this is
not what I'm accustomed to producing in
the sense that I have listened to this
kind of accents and I do have friends in
that country but um at the same time
it's a little bit difficult it's a
little bit difficult to speak this way
but if you are in in a place like for
further up north that's a different
matter and of course this is a kind of
accent that you got a lot of uh you have
to get accustom to it's the first time I
listen to it I say what the hell is
going on I don't understand anything
that's that's funny that's all it is so
I'm just switching between accents now
it's a little bit of mix of everything
it's like British or for example Irish
sometimes or Scottish depends when
you're in NE prob you have to speak like
that that's a different matter is this
is like a sample small short sample of
what this is like going I have to
exercise a little bit more because I was
caught completely off guard for your
request hey that that's how it works
best is
spontaneously yes yes I was just ranting
but you know well it's good so there you
go folks this is a man of many talents
and much hard work of course I am not
sure about that but thank you you very
much thank you for your time as always
Luca and if you have any further wacky
questions please post them in the
comments below and we'll get them in the
next video fantastic thank you Alex have
a fantastic day and bye to you all